welcome back to 820 special relativity
so in our quest
to understand how we get to general
relativity there's two things to
consider the first one this lecture is
not meant to give you a full description
of general relativity but just a view
into where this might lead where this
discussion might lead
so
in this quest
we can understand the theory of
general relativity as a theory on how to
patch together the different reference
frames which are each
can be described in special relativity
so in the framework we discussed up to
now
and is valid in short intervals in space
time
consequence of general relativity are
that space time is curved so we have
modified geometries
um and we learned that because of
gravitational effects matter curves
space-time
as a consequence of that you know there
must be modification of of gravity based
on meta distributions and so there must
also be gravitational waves
gravitational lenses which bend light
black holes
and there's cosmological predictions
coming out of general relativity
so let's have a discussion first
what does it mean to have a changed or
modified geometry
what could that mean
so you're all used to euclidean geometry
where when you draw a
triangle you add up all the angles to
180 degrees if you draw two parallel
lines they never cross they also don't
diverge
but if you have a modified geometry
for example the geometry on the sphere
like on our globe
the angles do not add up to 180 degrees
they actually the sum is larger than 180
degrees and parallel lines will cross we
would call this kind of space positively
curved
but you can have the opposite example
like on a saddle
so you can have other spaces and other
curved spaces and they can be negatively
skirved in this example if you add up
all angles you find they add up to less
than 180 degrees
parallel lines will not cross but they
will diverge
okay so
mass has changed the geometry of
spacecraft time you know we just talked
about light bending
and because of the change in geometry
light will not go on a straight line
anymore but will bend around massive
object space time is
curved geometry of space-time tells us
how the masses move
you can think about
um a trampoline when you put a heavy
object on a trampoline
all the other objects on the trampoline
will gravitate towards the heavier
object and that's kind of a picture on
how spacecraft spacetime actually looks
like
einstein
used those finding in order to redefine
newton's first law and found the
so-called einstein field equation
so there's on one side of the equation
there's a description of space time and
its curvature
and on the other side of the equation is
the energy momentum momentum tensor the
description and how energy energy and
momentum of object is distributed
and those two things space time and
energy and momentum they're kind of
interlinked in this in this equation
so if you read this description you can
read it from one side to the next space
time tells matter how to move
or you read it from the other direction
say
meta tell space crime space time how to
curve
there is an equation and you can just
read it from the left to the right or
from the right to the left so our
understanding here
it says space and time are not fixed
things
you know
[Music]
matter
through which matter and energy moves
through
the matter and energy then itself
defines space-time
and matter because of that time sp
space-time is dynamical it's changing
it's interacting with the matter and
with the energy
this is a super exciting picture from
hubble
the hubble space telescope and you see
galaxies um but what you also see
is those structures which looked like
something the light has gone through
lenses those lenses are actually meta
distributions galaxies themselves which
actually lead to the bending of the
light and those lensing effects
okay if you want to summarize um general
relativity you can first say that space
time is curved and it follows the pseudo
romanian monifold with a specific metric
we have seen the metric before with
minus plus plus plus
and the relationship between matter and
curvature is given by the einstein
equation and here i give you a slightly
different form where there is the
dynamics again on one side and the
energy momentum on the other side
let's just look at one
example here so we discussed in special
relativity invariant intervals right and
we had this delta s squared or we had
different name for i
given by minus dt square plus dx square
plus dy square plus dz squared we could
have just written this in polar
coordinates as well where you find the d
r square and r square d theta square and
then r square
sine square theta d phi squared
okay same thing it's just a different
coordinate system
so
as a solution
to einstein equation we find something
which looks very very similar that's not
a surprise as we
find general relativity as a patchwork
of small spaces of general special
relativity
so the solutions might be very similar
okay in the solution found here by the
so-called schwarzschild solution which
are unique solution vacuum with
spherical symmetry
of a meta distribution so you have a
spherical meta distribution like our sun
right and this is solution which
describes
um space time around this you find this
invariant interval here has two
interesting features
there's two
singularities in here
so you find this should be a minus one
you find those two singularities one is
at r equals zero that's kind of expected
in the middle of the mass distribution
this thing is not defined anymore
there's no mass left
but there's also a second singularity at
two gm
this is called the so-called
schwarzschild radius
and it defines
if you get to the singularity
you basically don't define anymore this
invariant interval
you can think about the black hole the
surface of a black hole as this
singularity
at this r values at those singularities
everything becomes timeline time like or
everything within the radius becomes
time-like
you